back time to code some
more I want to fix this freaking
right it's definitely an off by one
right
uh I want to figure out how we get this
thing working just just perfect
right see if I go over
here yeah so I
it's very weird because like some of
these look decent
it's hitting on this side and this side
it looks like and then it hits early
here
right do it hit early
there yeah wait no it didn't hit early
it hit late on both didn't it
is this scale wrong or
something
wait very
confused let me look at the original
code
I would like to get this um
Oops why stream not show up doesn't show
his online I should be fine oh yeah
there we
go all right so
extent gets multiplied by render
scale plus X Plus
y right
fine you seem like these would be in the
correct position to me
what about the
guides and the guides are like
something position
so create
epic I got I got to reply to that email
to set up something with you still um
but yeah I if next week is good I will
be
good the rendering is not working fully
I I don't want to spend a huge huge
amount of time on this but it is really
cool and uh I mean Captain put a ton of
effort into the end so I figured it may
as well have a nice renderer
right it seems like I broken
broken something or other
here it's like things are going through
the thing I can't tell is it seems like
you're going it's going through all the
walls no
well is it like partially going through
the walls here
maybe it's definitely going through
those walls
right I mean these yeah these collisions
don't seem bad at the bottom it seems
like the collisions are wrong up
here hang on is
that that pixel is supposed to be 0
oh why not C style
C++ with C exported inter interface for
python why is there like a better
binding
U that you would suggest
because C style C++ what do not just
mean just
python I honestly haven't played around
with too many different binding types
for this type of stuff like we have
pbind for a couple very small things in
Dev but we've mostly been using scyon
because we started out trying to provide
like a scon interface for researchers
because that would be easier uh and then
we just moved to c because it was like
really
simple there really aren't things from
C++ that I want unless there's like
better binding uh interfaces
maybe I don't really want standard lib
though I really don't want
polymorphism like the Zen of the Zen of
C for me is just that like you don't
need all these things and it's just
easy type VAR and python I I actually
really don't like typed python python is
like it's slow but the advantage is it's
it's very flexible and very
succinct um if I'm going to type my code
I may as well write
fast I kind of like both ends of it
right I like having a untyped or you
know I'd like to have a um a dynamically
typed uh nice scripting language like
Python and then I like to have you know
typed rigid but very very simple
language like
C like the main pain points here aren't
even the C the main pain points here are
um the design of box 2D for the most
part why this is Sol by one like check
this everywhere I can think
of width over
two over two
thickness all thickness is four
oh okay that's
something semi agree just
implemented go
to we need to return to that types can
be useful Plus have bladed something
help in building a
system
H like maybe
yeah but
like it's also kind of the thing where
you shoot yourself in the foot so many
times and there's so many things to
think about like how do I not screw it
up I'd rather just have the simple thing
and do it
well like I don't like I just don't want
to deal with the like the thing right
like why should I why should I deal with
these things if I can kind of just write
whatever I want in like brain dead
simple code and have it work and have it
be faster you most of the time as
well it's kind of funny like most of the
time I write stuff in C it ends it being
shorter than the python shorter than
whatever else faster and simpler it just
like you win on every possible
know there's really nothing I
miss I think I missed Vector for a bit
and then I realized that like actually I
don't want vector
um maybe set but like most of the time
it's like when you want to use a set you
just shouldn't be using a
set I mean like it's it's funny how
quickly you change your view on a lot of
things like python you use dictionaries
everywhere for everything right and then
like I really haven't ever had a spot
where dang I just need a dictionary here
it just doesn't happen
low implementing our own compilers
instead of relying
on programming
is ever read sigp no I mean I really
don't do I'm pretty new to low-l Dev
honestly like I've been just writing
python for like 10 years because of
research and then just in the last year
because of puffer lib right I've been
doing a lot of lower level Dev and it's
just it's been really
chill you know if you do things in just
the simplest way possible things are
just transferable as well I
mean you can write C you can write Cuda
it's the same thing if you write really
simple C you can literally just paste
your code into Cuda and it works as well
that's fun
um and it's been like I haven't really
hit any bottlenecks
where I've needed anything
else it's kind of just been like yeah
Implement whatever and have it be
relatively chill
IR respectable low levels where it's
at yeah I mean it's I spent a whole
bunch the funny thing about it is I
spent so many years writing Python and
it literally took me 3 weeks before I
was just as comfortable in C so I don't
know if it was just the way that I was
deving in Python to begin with but it
was really easy
yeah they don't quite touch on something
definitely there's like an offset issue
it's weird that the collisions actually
look good to me on one
side hang on
wait it didn't look good
before they definitely don't look good
on the
left but wait how would they look good
on one side only
looks good to me
bang
yeah oh that's a good way to see it
yeah the mine is totally stuck in the
correct spot there maybe that's the
Strat is go get the
I want to see where the mine
sticks that should tell me something at
least oh it's weird that that one's also
positioned
yeah ah look right there now you can see
it right
so that can't just be an off by one
right because it sticks it sticks on the
correct place on the left side and then
it sticks on the right side it
uh a scaling
bug it should be off on both sides then
it should be off on both sides
you Cube map visualizer or while
wireframe
mode I mean I can put wireframes on
these it doesn't really help it didn't
like I can see what's happening I just
can't think of why like what would cause
that behavior right so the bounces are
good on the right side and the bottom
side yeah but like what type of offset
error would cause
that I would think it would be wrong on
both sides
then it's only wrong on one
side Ian you can see the projectiles
they're going all the way to the left
corner the left um the left left wall
transformation Direction
Vector like of
what speed it can't be the speed Vector
now the physics are correct the physics
are tested good in a different renderer
so it's that the walls aren't where the
walls actually like the walls in the
engine aren't where the walls look
here oh wait hang
on let me see something
here look really
close no I was thinking maybe the grid
isn't lined up
up ah the grid isn't lined
up that's
yeah how's that
horizontally and does it line up
vertically
oh wait no it
does yeah that's just the
perspective
[Music]
oh I can't no it isn't hang
on
four it's the width of the first Cube
not being accounted
for it's using the middle of the first
Cube as 0 0
up the first Cube yeah it looks like
that but is that
wrong oh I think that actually does it
depend hang on that depend on the map
because in the other map it wasn't going
through the center of the cubes it was
lined up with the edges
wait wait yeah there is something weird
with the map loading hang
on yeah so in this one here it's in the
center 0 0 is the center of this Plus
it's the same for all of
them
okay I swear that before though there
were Maps where it was it was not lined
up that way
hang on this one is
different this one is X this one is
lined up
differently yeah this one is lined
differently
okay does that tell me
anything other than just the maps being
placed weirdly
let's reset this to uh something that's
easier to
yeah we can see there in the
middle the
grid and those tubs also don't look like
they are the
right
oh well that's how um hang on
dummy let's fix
this first
issue looting wall thickness
start
is there we go
these now move around correctly don't
they they still look high don't they are
they still high on these floating
walls some of them look
good I just died a tile off which is
interesting
these look like they're lined up with
the
top like when they get yeah when they
look they get close they're lined up
with the
top let me think if I can figure out
why negative wall thickness to two times
wall thickness
right size of this is sling
thickness this should
two just
zero no it's not zero right
odd am I sure that's what it
is or is this just like another weird
render
thing hang on on this side doesn't it
look like it's
I mean it's it's really hard to tell if
these
are where they're supposed to
be it's also really hard to control the
Drone from
here
uh well I don't think that they bump
correctly oh maybe that's why they look
um maybe it's the collisions that make
them
weird yeah cuz that won't Collide right
but then this one yeah yeah yeah so
what's happening is it's okay so these
are at the right hype the collisions are
still wrong okay and then let's do the
0.5 where's this render weapon
pickup
zero .5 F yeah this is all at like a
reasonable spot it's just I think it's
just getting rendered
wrong pause X pause
y actually that's like a
good good test if these are on top of
each other
it's maybe it's these guys that
aren't playing
nicely CU these could be wrong too right
I think they
are let see how how did he draw these
the first
time he did origin thickness over
two okay
okay
so we have shotgun in a wall
you know now it doesn't look like
it's it's going all the way wrong it
just looks like it's half
wrong yeah it's only okay hang on on let
me go
um so I think I did mess with something
here that's
wrong W pause
X
pause
X it should be
minus
okay that sticks
maybe it's hard to see if it's sticks to
be
honest I don't see any more more uh
floating pickups though
overlapping the walls which is a good
clipping that looked good that bounce
looked good
now yeah that's instant bounce right
that's a correct bounce so if it's
bouncing uh and it will look like so it
looks like it's going over the top I
think because it's
rendering is it rendering on top of the
wall I think it's rendering on top of
the wall let me
check see when do I bounce
it looks like I'm just rendering on top
of everything which I am right the gun
is sticking
through so maybe it is a render order
thing now because I
think yeah yeah hang on I think this is
now just a render order thing we had a
few different
bugs but now I think it's just render
order okay
problem what research topics would you
recommend for somebody looking to do a
PhD in RL
that's a tough one because really the
main problems at the moment with RL is
it's not that there's like missing super
fancy stuff it's that we've done all the
basics wrong as a
field so I'd honestly look to some of
the type of stuff we're doing with
puffer at the moment
um I mean a PhD is not necessarily just
like one algorithm or like one very
specific thing within RL like RL is
already specific
enough I mean the types of stuff we're
looking at at the moment
are I mean we're looking at the
diversity is all un need stuff for
exploration to see if there's something
to that we're looking still at e3b for
exploration we're looking at our new
algorithm work on trying to replace
Advantage
estimation um I mean outside of that
stuff like there are a lot of
possibilities maybe there's something to
model based right maybe there's
something to off policy they're like
there's so many different areas but the
problem is there's literally no way of
evaluating what's promising or even what
works because everything is like all the
experiments are so slow and haven't been
tuned so literally we have no idea
what's better than what like what is
better than another thing thing a thing
B we don't know which one's better um
the thing is that's tough is it's a
tough area to do a PhD in and in fact I
think Academia really actively
disincentivizes this type of work so
frankly it's just a very very tough
time uh in Academia for RL because like
RL is being held back by the baggage
created by Academia and we kind of need
to get outside of the Norms of that in
order to fix it it's tough need puffer
to standard it's not just a standard
things like there have been so many RL
standardization efforts it's not
standardization it's like speed
exhaustive re exhaustive
experimentation um getting basic nuts
and bolts right I mean so so many things
um does Ray just draw
stuff on the order I'm
confused may I can test this pretty
easily can't
I here I should just test it
okay 0
Z let's put this like
four this would be like
one and then I draw another Cube on top
of it but I draw that one first
thing I like how you get just like this
ridiculous errors for something so
simple it's
ridiculous
okay I can't see it it's too
small do
so this is on top and then this is on
the bottom so it should
be oh and then this is too big should go
it eight Canan Cube stacked on green
Cube Canan Cube stacked on green cube
right and this works perfectly and I
drew the sign Cube
first and I drew the green Cube under it
and it renders
because there are like several
somethings I think that are weird at
this point
let's see if I figure out why the grid
is offset this
it that's not what we see
here
right we see ne8 or whatever
go8 I got to fix that weird
permissioning thing causing those errors
at some
up we could try um let's try negative
7 this should just barely intersect the
walls yeah yes yes it
does okay so we are at8 for some
reason um but then the question is why
we shouldn't be
why 5 is
8 Y starts ne4
stupid with height float length
draw a cube width height float
length how would this function have to
work for me to be wrong here right draw
a
cube if you to draw the cube at
it damn it
I think I see the
right yeah I think I see the issue hang
on let's confirm but I'm pretty sure I
see
it that's obnoxious that's so obnoxious
whoops yep okay you draw cubes from the
center I didn't
realize that actually makes the uh the
API
the heights are all wrong so we got to
fix the
heights yeah we got to fix so much
there we
go now it goes behind
correctly projectiles bound
correctly cubes are hopefully
looking be the correct
position
see we will confirm but I think they
should
be yeah that's good
oh yeah they're getting
rotated we got to check the uh the
actual
we fixed a bunch of stuff
Captain I'll back in Discord if you're
okay sure thing Captain answer this
quick email and I'll be back on this
all right
cool oh and there's uh more Dev on
this all
right let's do this until captain gets
back
so Map size Maybe
be
fixed Z I
believe no columns
are variable Z fixed X which is with
this
o
or *
this crazy woodpecker that just likes to
fly into the window
you have to take a little bit you have
to take a thickness over two off of this
right that even a half
some of these maps are aligned and
others aren't just The Annoying Thing
why is it like slightly off now oh you
can't you should be able to do this
that's
cool that now
see there's no thickness because it's
not a cylinder
lighting oh it's in the do H actually
not the dot C my
bad it is
trater okay perfect
so
do comments or lies just read cheat
cheat that's
funny I'm trying to think where we want
to put lights on
these we're going to start with the the
box I
guess if you put a light inside of his
spere though like if I put it inside of
the bot I guess I have to put it above
the bot or below the bot
lights above would be a good place to
start
above any of this stuff
oh above the B yeah
okay and
then youve got these lighting
shaders so you need Shader as well don't
you Shader
the I wish my auto complete would not
just randomly break on me it's really
we don't have create
light
is right
side
oh
cool like this
happens white
Point
somewhere Ray Li Ray math
rlg ah r
lights. no R lights you had to copy
something
huh no you didn't have to copy something
so where is
it I do not see an R lights
in
Raab why don't we have it
well don't like I don't act like I'm
happy about
I don't see our lights it's a bonus
file so I have to get it
separately is that what I'm hearing
thing so did you really just grab the
most basic
Shader then as is that all that is that
all you
did yes
s like what lighting Shader did you
get I mean it's pretty easy if we wanted
to like actually make stuff look really
good cuz like you just grab like a
fancier lighting Shader that does
Reflections and does you know all sorts
of stuff up
um the split file structure with all
these [ __ ]
includes oh yeah no and it looks good it
just could look even
better so I think that the light is
inside this Cube so let's delete the
these cubes
the Shadows yeah you need a Shader that
has
Shadows it doesn't just do it it's not
like it's actually simulating you know
light um unless you're doing Ray tracing
so everything needs to be done separate
well why don't I see the
light I do not see the
light let's see what you're
Shader Spa a sphere where the light is
doesn't go through the sphere does it go
through I can tell you it's not
missed I missed something with the
Shader
go light is not you have to
do begin Shader so you draw everything
with the Shader on basically
right begin Shader mode so begin mode
again okay still no
light well I
forget set Shader value
I think I need to set the Shader
V
hello hey we're trying to get
lights nice uh what's your vision with
the lighting have
lighting fair
enough not flat shading
um were you able to figure out the whole
like Collision stuff
yes
nice how hard was that kind of ass but
was stupid it was just the are actually
drawn from The Middle
yeah you have to draw them from like the
corner or something right no they are
actually drawn from the middle I thought
that they were drawn from the corner
like a
rectangle oh I mean that makes it easy
but yeah that's that's interesting huh
yeah well it doesn't say like Center X
it's just gets you pause so it doesn't
it was unclear yeah that is unclear I
mean it's nice that we now know that but
yeah that's not super clear the docks
don't say that anywhere in
RB well I mean it's like go go draw a
cube and see how it draws you more on
right it's like okay fine I mean I guess
but docs would like docs that made sense
good Raab cheat sheet very good I
actually I honestly am kind of happy
with the cheat sheet over the docks I
guess it would be nice if you it like
linked if you could click the things and
it would just take you to the function
or whatever that would be
nice but I don't know ra PE pretty good
yeah one thing I do find useful if I'm
trying to use some third-party API that
I haven't like some code that I haven't
written and it's not doing what I expect
a lot of times I'll just look and see
how it's implemented and figure it out
from there if the documentation is
lacking that is that the code is the
documentation yeah it's like why do you
need the thick code explained in English
do you not know how to read code are you
a
literate sometimes the code is
sufficiently complex that it makes sense
to have docs it's funny though
it I mean it also saves you time because
figuring out code is not trivial a lot
of times figuring out dcks is not
trivial programmers are better at
programming than they are at
writing yeah docks good docks are hard
naming is
hard do I have to set these Shader
values every frame or something for this
to do
anything it shouldn't
right
so is there anything so I know I just
finished uh like a little bit ago um I
got all the black hole stuff like
completely working it was working when I
showed you guys but then I tried
training with it and it and pretty
quickly encountered some um bugs which
I've since fixed training seems fine I
haven't seen any bugs and benchmarking
or playing or anything so yeah that that
should be taken care of is there
anything directly I can do to
help let me
think or maybe I can do something I can
do concurrently
or I guess
simultaneously
ah Spencer how hard is it to get like
animations
integrated o do you think we need
animations or do you think we just do
more
procedural I honestly think we do them
all procedure like what what animations
would we even
want explosions and stuff I don't
know yeah I mean we can just use
procedural effects for that can't we
maybe if we're good at procedural
effects true did you add the dep light
implementation
constant yeah I
did what's this client camera position I
assume this is something
else are relevant for this m maybe
not then maybe we just need good
lighting good lighting and good
procedural yeah
we'll see how these this lighting Works
maybe we do really good lighting I don't
know I was just going to attach a light
to all the bullets
I don't know if we need attach a light
to them shouldn't we just be able to put
a GL a bloom effect on
them you possibly do
both oh
really so the bloom effect makes him
look glowy the light effect actually
makes them light up the cubes like the
walls when to get
near eventually for Call of puffer I
will be bothering Captain to teach
me actually hey Spencer there there is a
call of puffer
update I'm chatting with Brendan next
week and uh he actually has like a FPS
madona n that runs fast on the actual
Call of Duty maps oh oh right I I called
it call of puffer I was like what is
call of puffer call of
puffer I forgot I coined that not that
it's that like original or anything hey
careful if you keep saying puffer I'll
replace the uh the ship model in here
this sphere with a
puffer I don't think that would work for
this game you don't think so I get the
3D puffer model it puffs up when it's
shielding or
careful sorry sir your your uh your ship
model has been replaced by a puffer
legit Cod Maps
yeah I don't know if they're open source
the Cod Maps but they are open sourcing
the um the game it'll be cool that is
cool I I don't know they probably won't
open source the maps but they will open
source the game maybe they'll open
source the maps that'd be
awesome maybe I mean if even if they
just open source like one basic map or
something so you could try out the game
locally captain gets the 3D puff and I
well I have to find the 3D pop so I've
never done I didn't bother doing that
still really sure it would be
don't oh wait float three camera paes
just not allowed to be a back I
see literally it knows what this is
already float camera
pause of three
okay I did find um one what it just the
game looks cool oh yeah man that that
looks way better
man I don't think it's particularly good
to play uh well first of it sucks to
play with a mouse uh with this because
the mouse is well the mouse is wrong
right now with the iso
so I honestly don't even think it would
be bad to play in ISO with the mouse
compared to normal with the
mouse if with the controller you could
probably as as long as it's still aiming
correctly which I think it would be yeah
if we could get it to we would just have
to fix the aiming that's separate though
right
yeah and why Spencer why don't these
lights show
up why why lights not work why no light
why no
light oh so I I played um impulse Wars
on Steam a a little bit more and I
discovered uh I discovered a little bit
more of what they're doing with the
walls how we thought like only part of
them were transparent and part of them
weren't it's none of that it's
Reflections the um the walls are
reflective when you turn everything up
to Max huh so that's why you can
basically when you think you're seeing
through them you're seeing the grid
reflected back in the sides of them oh
so we just need a better lighter
lighting and then that works yeah I I
think maybe I don't know if you use the
material it might be more than
this but well yeah it'd be more than
this but for a start we could set the
material or something of the walls to be
like super like glossy or something like
a really well polished like marble floor
or something I don't know how that would
affect the lighting but I'd imagine it
get give it something like
that the Grid's kind of nice when it's
like subtle isn't it and it's like it
doesn't work in 2D but I think it works
in 3D no I agree that's what I said
before it's
good part of me is kind of tempted to
try and add the teleporter but I feel
like I don't need to add another weapon
right now yeah I think we get it to look
good first and then like you know we get
like if it looks like if it looks really
good then I think we can be like okay
update to this update to that
yeah do we need
this oh wait you need to apply the
material this is
it
Cube oh so if you don't apply materials
it it doesn't show up with lighting at
all I
guess
interesting was it Cube though C Cube
load oh shoot this is a how do you apply
them the Shader to uh how do you apply
the Shader to just like a normal Cube
Rock
Cube set Shader
value and this doesn't look bad to even
just begin with here
light yeah this is only for uh for
models that are loaded
the real test will be though once we get
this finally worked out it needs to have
the Precision of the 2D version because
yeah the 2D version is nothing special
but you can see it like the everything's
just kind of like Pixel Perfect in a
sense it's really easy to kind of tell
like where you are what's going to hit
you y y so as long as we have that it
should be the same because it's the
physics of the same
yeah
but how you render it makes all the
difference
though is what I'm saying as long as we
make it so it's you know still similar
in that regard I'm cool with
it I don't want to break the game that
would be a dumb thing to freaking
do that seems like a dumb thing to do
I did make one small uh like very very
small actually render change that won't
uh conflict with you at all I changed it
so when the Drone drones die and they
spawn the pieces the velocity of the
pieces are in like scaled based on how
fast the Drone was going when they hit
the
wall so a pretty small change but it's
kind of
cool if you barely like touch the wall
they don't really do much but if you
slam into the wall they go flying
are but uh I still can't see the
lights I just added a plane the base I
still can't see the light
is the
hell
shaders failed to open
what is that name like SLS like what is
that directory I
mean oh it's the
version
I should be percent
I I think it is because these numbers
don't make any
so this glsl version is not is there
something wrong here
glsl blsl
version this is not oh you
well that's
something
oh we got lighting it's gonna be
freaking cool when it
works Spencer second well something is
oh look at the lighting effects on the
sphere we can totally use that for
something whoa but uh it's total mess
here so I don't know what
happened did you uh did you get it
working uh you can see well I guess you
can't if you don't have the
REM no I'm in
my I was the delay on typing was just
like not ideal yeah yeah it can be
annoying okay freaking lighting is cool
oh you got it
working oh nice you got it well it it
lights but it doesn't light reasonably
so how do be yeah but hey that's a good
start there are okay yeah you just
needed yeah you just needed the version
right
yeah yeah I wasn't loading the
file and then set Shader what is the set
Shader value what what is this client
Shader Shader look Vector
view I don't know why I think that's
just GB I think it's say GPT
Mass so does this not do
anything well I don't know why the light
moves so
much it looks like the light keeps
moving yeah what the hell is
this oh is it just because it's in I
don't see it's in a box I think that
it's like getting obscured or
something that it kind of looks cool
though why is your light moving it
shouldn't be
go why is
it I don't know why it keeps
like why does it feel like it's over
here
somewhere like look also you're you're
spawning four lights in the same
place is that why is it like overlapping
or
something yeah I was wondering why
you're creating lights in a loop well
we're going to do stuff with
them are you going to have four lights
one in each
corner I was attach them to the
Box did you place the light inside of
the cube and try I didn't try
to well what the [ __ ] is
this why does it keep like doing this
this is spooky
this is turning into a horror
game it's kind of amazing how much
lighting transforms things honestly
that's yeah this is why I was like nope
we're gonna get it in 3D we're GNA get
Lighting on it we're gonna like you know
yeah because unless you're doing like
you know pixel art or like you've got
like an art style for 28 right
I mean to be fair you can also do 2D
shaders and make those really
cool yeah that's true I
guess that's
true also am I echoing it all for you
all I'm in my car just a little n you're
good all
right he's not
bad see I was curious Spencer how long
have you been working on GPU drive
because you seem to be making a lot of
progress in a pretty short amount of
time uh I don't know like a week and a
half dang so have you are you rewriting
it completely
andc yeah oh nice yeah that's cool yes
this is what we do here at poq we reite
[ __ ] and see I mean I know worth
is I just it's
really yeah visually I'm able to make a
lot of progress really quickly because
I'm given effectively all of the paths
of everything from the start so all I'm
doing is just like once I get all of the
data in I'm just loading it in the way
that it's supposed to be formatted and
then it just makes the visualization
already I'm not really like making a new
visualization move a light
but I am pleasantly you know moving
forward on the policy side so I'm just
trying to get you know I think next
thing I don't know if you were here when
we were talking about it but the next
item that I'm going to be focusing on is
like Lane collisions and object
collisions now that it can uh get to the
goal nice and then maybe sometime after
that like more robust like vehicle
physics or something oh this is I think
actually I want to do the vehicle
physics first I think I think I can try
and work on that this weekend because I
think I just did it wrong effectively
like I I don't think I'm taking into
account when I was looking at it there's
it's either it's called like the yaw or
the angular like like ratio which is or
like it's like the rate at which the the
new angle should be applied at per time
step it shouldn't just like teleport to
the
new uh heading yeah it should like apply
it via some degree of this bicycle model
which I just I probably was just trying
to power through yeah that makes sense
so yeah I think what I do is I want to
get the physics to be better to where
they're I think what they're supposed to
be so the steering is smoother retrain
the policy again to make sure that it
didn't screw up anything and then I'll
do clean Collision stuff
afterwards nice and then after I do
lisions then then I think maybe it'll be
time for Joseph and I to talk about
what's the best way to do the multi map
loading because then like memory gets a
little bit weird on terms of like are we
just going to Max pull all of the the
agents
or Max up size every time we're g do it
dynamically
yeah things like
cutting pretty
successful and this already 10 to 15
fter you know we're already at 00,000
of reason it's erratic but it goes from
like 1.6 million to 7 like 800,000
randomly we'll figure out that issue but
yeah my guy you've been replaced by a
robot
unfortunately how do you get the Drone
oh is my audio screwed
yeah is way to get the Drone positions
Captain yeah it should just be drone
pause yeah but how do you get the
drones
uh why don't you just why don't you just
move it in like render drone that would
be too
smart uh I guess but do they have an ID
to
them uh they do I mean you could Loop
over them again but it probably just
makes sense to do it in like a render
drone or something
own these things have an idea or
something that we had like did
we what do you want the color them
somehow didn't you yeah so it's drone
idx is the index drone and each drone
has a unique index okay drone Arrow idx
probably yeah idx is a member of the
Drone entity
struct all right I'll be back home in
like 30 minutes I'm just still in the
middle of
kind of nowhere
land Texas
right yeah I'm driving from Houston to
Dallas right now oh is that far I don't
know how that's pretty far
right for me it's like a five hour drive
oh
man yeah you you see me doing that
pretty often too that kind of
sucks yeah it's is what it is yeah so um
lighting seems a bit erratic is it still
erratic yeah it's still totally crazy
and
erratic Tred raising the the light
higher so you can kind of really see how
it's affecting things well maybe hang on
maybe maybe it is did you tie it to
something
maybe I thought are you
copying did you
copy
GPT no it's still going hold up I use
some brain
power well I don't know what this
is but it's kind of crazy look at this
[ __ ] like why does it do
this that's that's
weird this is impulse Wars epilepsy
addtion
add addiction
addition it wouldn't go quite that far
but yeah it's weird I would try what
spener said though just try raising them
up pretty high and then it should be
easier to see where they are they are oh
they are raised up really
high eight could be high enough raise
them to like
20 just I'm I'm telling you it'll make
your a lot easier if you just draw a
sphere where the light
is so that you can like visually see how
the light is like shooting out
everywhere and then put them back into
the proper locations
afterwards I don't know if it's moving
with the Drone correctly though like I
don't know if this is actually the
somehow like I don't know how to like I
don't know how to get the position of it
like aren't you just spawn the light in
a fixed location at the
start well okay here now it's at the
center so there it was at the center and
but you can see in the top Corner maybe
we'll not move it no but you see at the
the top Corner um well not even Corners
the very top because of this isometric
angle I saw like lights moving up there
it looked like at
least render
drone where did I put this thing then
put this
in render drone guides for some
reason but it's still going to be screwy
I
think now see it's
like I don't know why it
shifts yeah I'm not sure you can right
it
moves
yeah oh wait wait wait is it tied to the
arrow keys like are you moving it with
the camera
somehow it could be I don't touch if I
don't touch any controls it still moves
I think
anything if I move now does it like do
anything
are you applying a transformation M are
trying are you apping a transformation
matrix anywhere that you're act not
closing
is Vector 3 create light hang on create
light
does this come
from light
light Max
lights Max Dynamic light supported by
Shader is four
us why is that I can we just increase
the
max maybe I
don't I mean it's just a constant right
like Jack that baby up I think they
might be hardcoded
on position
Target was a
Target position Target color
up I bet you they have Z
up what do we think on the odds of
this uh what is z up we'll see if it's
you'll see if it's true
update
light oh that's
maddening we can get this to work we can
like make this look so damn good as
well yeah no I'm definitely starting to
see it
now oh it's nowhere even close no I know
but I'm I'm starting to see the
potential okay we just saw very clearly
that it just jumped a whole
and you don't update the position right
now right you just set it and it
the lights are just clearly freaking
moving oh this is
do
this be
down decided to try and ask an LM huh
well I just like is there a common
bug yeah I don't know this is
this is
weird why is it teleporting everywhere
huh okay
um what if you're only wait would this
even make
sense I was going to say what if you
don't render everything except the light
um and just see if it's still
teleporting like maybe something some
other render call is like messing with
it well it needs to there needs to be
something to
render uh I don't know you just render a
spere or something like z z and that's
it I I don't know just like Fast com a
bunch of code
sure
yeah that's I don't know that's kind of
the only thing I can think of
so it's not
moving is it the freaking translate
wait what the hell is
this was is what oh wait no this
is draw texture code
jumps well when do you use draw texture
code point or
whatever uh drawing fonts I
believe this is the one that I was
thinking of
oh wait that makes it draw no
walls oh you just yeah
you did it is it when it gets a
pickup
what no
no yeah what's the wait is it when Pro
try shooting at it because projectiles
like pass through it and then I think it
no never mind I I can't shoot it CU
stuff's in the
way I don't know what's causing it it's
not flickering as much but it was I
wonder if we let's do the other was it
draw text
fering Still fck well hang on maybe was
that a that could be a box was on
it maybe it shouldn't be though come to
think of it I
think but won't the boxes not affected
if they're not being rendered
uh
true because RB doesn't know about
them right
now it's not moving but it's still
flickering all right how about this go
edit the demo file to make sure the
opponents are like sitting ducks and
then you're the only one moving and then
maybe we can try and pinpoint like if it
responds to any movement or if it's just
like somewhat R where do I do Sitting
Ducks is it this last SC
uh it's the second to last
true I forgot the last one is set
duck make it easier to test some stuff
anyway I lost to sitting
ducks I mean to be fair the walls are
invisible
okay you could make it two players too
that's just one other line change and
then if once you die it'll it'll just
restart for
you just at the top just change numb
drones to be um well it's not I want to
see if it cuz it's not flickering I want
the map back
yeah wait are bursts being rendered they
will burst very infrequently so maybe
it's related to bursting we'll
see oh yes it is
jumping it's jump
yeah H I've took a pickup and it jumped
again and it jumped again pick
up it jumped I think it is related to
this these translations or something
the burst look really
cool okay so it's the uh it is I found
it see if I'm
correct should
work okay so now stuff is still being
drawn
yeah there we
go and
Ducks there we go
I was UN mute again so the problem was
just not ending the Shader mode yep
apparently the mate you cannot have a
buffer Spencer was actually
right I didn't realize that you actually
have to like you can't have that
translate that Matrix op uh in a Shader
block you have to end and then
begin huh
weird we're going to have to clean up
this code cuz I've been making a [ __ ]
mess with
it yeah once you get stuff working well
I guess it is pretty much working now
yeah it is working that is correct is
fact
working well so there's your
light going to do them on the box
and then you're going to move the lights
on every frame
there are lights but I don't think that
they're where they think that they
should uh I don't think that they are
where I think they
either where' you place them oh you
tried to place them on the drones
wait e client
Shader
lights but you're not doing anything
with light pause like you don't do
anything with the update lights values
with light
pause there a
pointer I update
position oh wait unless this
take I'm a bit confused as to how this
isn't just copying the Shader
oh cuz this is just the location
maybe it's
like is it the wrong type of light yeah
I think it's working just uh but like
this is not what a point light should
look
like for drones don't you want an
omnidirectional light that's a point
light what's the difference I thought
you'd want an omnidirectional light that
yes that's called a point light oh they
same thing
yes cuz a point light sounds like it
should point at like it be ative that's
a spotl oh okay a point light is a light
that is just a
point okay I thought there's some I saw
there's something different but probably
I guess not doesn't look like it's going
where it's like
think it's like this would be like it's
the wrong type of light this is like a
spotlight what how's a Target oh hold on
G
Light
Blue 2f Shad hang on
it's just really weird like what would
cause this you know Point
like can a pointl
even do that what this is like what
we're seeing
here Ian it's clearly it's like focused
around around the
it's like stretching the light from the
center
anything I mean this has to be doing
something right
because yeah that's the only place
they're moving
yo hey I can't figure out what's wrong
with this Shader Spencer we got your
light well we got this but like I'm
trying to I can't see what what your
this is let me
um I'm back in my apartment I just I
just need to tune in the Stream just
give me a
sec I need to mute you so I don't hear
double audio
Yeah Okie do come on internet power
through
where Okie do what am I looking at here
why are
there why are there light cones running
around exactly so like there're supposed
to just be Point lights that are moving
with the drones but somehow they're like
cones that are facing Center why are
there oh okay I muted all right you're
good
now um yeah it's like for some
reason there are like you see when I
move it looks like the cone is like
facing the center
it looks like the cones are facing away
from the center or away from the center
then sure so they're facing the Drone
but
like it's a wait but you that means you
you tied it to something then well we're
trying to move it with the
Drone but it's supposed to but where are
you trying to station it though like
where's your where's your starting point
of like what is it end goal is it
supposed to stay above the Drone is it
supposed to just like have a light above
the
Drone okay and for now you're just
having them all stay in the center no
this is a
bug I can't figure out why it's not
going with the
Drone I presume you have your drone
positions right
yes and I'm guessing you tried that and
that doesn't work for it's like it's not
are they even spawning on top of the
drone at
all uh well it's being updated
immediately to the
Drone like it's created and then they
get tied to the Drone right
that so I can't think why this would
okay so your drone. paa
dox you set your y to be fixed because
that's the height you want it at I
presume and
then you're updating are so are you
manually calling update light values
right now
yeah are you not supposed
to I don't remember let me take a look a
tower climb I thought you
were I may I mean I may be you
see if not it might be something inside
of our lights That's Just
Happening oh wait you know what I bet I
bet I know what it is [ __ ]
[ __ ] I bet I know what it
is bet it's the GPT boiler plate
I love how GPT is like the best tool
ever for writing garbage
code just
awesome don't know I thought that would
be it for
sure okay let's go to my render stuff
because okay
if you were to right now if you were to
spawn them in the static location are
they staying static
yep okay so
the so the light itself is not
moving but you're you feel confident
that they're because it looks like
they're not even spawning where the well
no they're not spawning there but I can
just do this
when you're making client do you know
where the drones are
spawn um probably not but it gets moved
immediately like it it's so it's
underneath or whatever right here it's
in the
center yeah and then if I uncomment just
this one okay so it's at least staying
still right like it's it's not we fixed
that one okay you fixed that yeah we
fixed that one that was just you were
right it was a push
Matrix okay that makes
sense okay is render drone being yeah I
presume render drone is being called at
every
yep EAS
[Music]
game okay okay and so what's happening
right now it's its Target is being
adjusted uh I'm not trying to do that
and it shouldn't make a difference cuz
Point lights don't have
targets that is but they have Direction
I think do they they shouldn't it's a
point
it I mean I guess it doesn't have
Direction but I guess like if there's
nothing behind it it acts as if it has
direction if it's only hitting one thing
that it can hit well yeah there's
nothing behind it it'll but it's like
there's lots of Stu it'll present as the
direction but yeah yeah it doesn't like
actually have Direction okay
um okay what I do looks like it does
here right because it's like these look
like
spotlights this looks exactly like if I
had spotlights and I were just pointing
them at the bot I don't understand and
why okay can I see this code anywhere
right
here no I mean like from like on like a
link or something in I need to how do I
see I need to I cloned this so I think I
actually have to move this to a
for I
think yeah either that or if you just
want to copy paste it all into like a
chat or something and I can a lot of of
changes you can just uh change your
remote once you fork and then then you
should be able to commit yeah let me do
that CU I don't think I ever moved my
lights from
Spawn yeah I never tried moving my light
but I'm certain it can't be that
bad like there's no way it's that big of
an issue
offer so was it get remote set or
whatever
it's something like that I always just
ask GPT for what the exact command is
for that
oh apparently you can make the light
directional but I guess they're they're
currently light points they shouldn't be
CU it's yeah that would be a
spotlight what
did the stuff has
changed H what did you change in here
floating wall output size different
what commit were you pulling from uh
Master yeah what commit on Master
latest yeah I just I'm not sure what I
pushed I have three unpushed commits
so you must be have wait what's your
current commit CU I haven't changed
policy in like a
week yikes
I just
well yeah I
guess hold on you can keep editing this
just go out and I want to know like what
you're currently
on yeah I thought it was more recently I
don't I didn't think I change
policy get log what's show commit get
log
weird one of these frag position must be
like an open Gil
thing is this more re
it's which of these the more recent ones
the top one isn't
it uh
I don't think this looks like you swept
it I didn't sweep it in the last like
couple
days args are different the train args
are different I have you changed them no
because I haven't changed them in a long
time see
there be on a different Fork yeah is
it's the top one it's good same
Fork I think that my the version I
started reviewing was just
old yeah I I I guess but that's weird I
thought yeah you you did a clean
clone I thought so
map and handling these merge complex by
hand is kind of annoying BS code just
makes it kind of easy
yeah I don't know why so much of this
stuff is different this is weirding me
out well honestly it is easy even if I
were in this I just don't I like I don't
do enough merge work where I actually
know how to do this like at all
well
yeah what I'll probably just have to do
is once this is actually ready to PR
I'll probably just have to I mean you're
pretty much only changing the render
code so if anything else has changed
I'll probably just revert it back to
what it was okay what the heck scripted
Bots has has not been that small for
like a
month go back to scripted
bot what something weird is going on
here oh [ __ ] what the
[ __ ] oh scripted bot wait never mind
scripted agent is the new one do I still
have that in the
repo no I
don't it's not even in the repo deleted
it like a month ago I don't know what
the heck is going
on what did you do
man I think it's just an
old is this the same repo that um you
were reviewing on because I watched you
CL
that it's this I'm this is really
confusing me
floats like there are conflicts all over
the place but you didn't modify any of
this stuff
M does it make
sense well I got to go for the night
unfortunately but uh just I don't know
hit hit me up if you keep at it and
running
reward I didn't don't think I remove
that
now
oh this is no longer
existing can you just like re like copy
the render Doh and then just like Rec
than that I think at this point well
what all did you change besides render I
don't know
I mean I know you added some reviews
comments but like the render is the main
thing like we can save those but I'm
thinking like just copy yeah I just want
to make sure that I just want to make
sure that I get a commit of this that
works to a fork before like before we
[ __ ] up and like delete
everything okay sure but yeah but after
that maybe I would just try like the
more nulear approach because like there
should not be any of these conflicts
these most of these conflicts involve
code I haven't changed in weeks so so
something is very wrong with like it or
yeah all right I gotta go though hit me
up if you have any questions later dude
thanks though see you action
no invalid storage class what in the
[ __ ]
yeah we might have to like try to
reclone some
stuff I don't know why like well now I
feel bad I feel like I opened up
Pandora's Box just
trying I don't know this is why I don't
try to do stuff like that with get CU
it's always
91 commits
behind I just ored it what in the
okay do this again don't
I
want to get this up and synced at
I want to get this up and synced at least really like to fix that lighting
least really like to fix that lighting
bug
too I feel pretty confident we can solve
it it's just a weird
light that's from the r lights file
which I have
because [ __ ] no the renderer loads and
it just doesn't
render
weird
maybe is there in
main think we didn't do
camera there we go and now this looks
about like what it looked before
oh did you figure it out yeah P the
ass okay so let's before I [ __ ] you
know something else up
okay so now this will be in the puffer
fork and if you want to help me look at
it that'd be great I want to just finish
getting like the initial thing done and
go get food CU I haven't done that much
today fair enough okay let me uh so he
says in the puffer Fork
now oh impulse Wars
okay just updated now okay where are we
looking at source and
render all righty
let's find your
lights render drone light
pause these really do look like the
spotlights pointed at the
Drone they really feel like directional
lights
mhm they should even though I know you
have them you set them at light point
right
that what are you doing create
light light Point yeah yeah you did
light Point
okay all right so you're spawning
them okay let's see where else do you
call clamp lights
is
uh wait what light pause
equals e
is that how it works is it a pointer to
X well yeah but it also makes a cop like
this function require like takes a copy
anyways which is kind of
this what if you just made a new not new
but I guess instead of do just affecting
the
position MH okay how do I Des cribe
CL yeah what if you just make a new
light and then assign it to client
um I think you want to keep recreating
lights do
you I mean it's probably not the best
way but I'm just seeing if that will
actually do what we're at least I want
to see if it spawns it in the correct
spot do
that because right now I'm questioning
that it's it's even getting it's the how
you're getting position dox to go to it
is seemingly something's
they're probably end up making it oh
actually I don't know we'll see
also I don't call update light values
anywhere in Tower climb but I guess I'm
not
actually I don't know if that does
anything this doesn't seem
to yeah this doesn't seem to work at
all this doesn't update the lights at
all if you do
this okay
work I just don't get why it's s sping
somewh
El yeah this is a global here so what
you can't make more than
four that's why this doesn't
work oh okay so you have to up update
the existing
lights and it is a vector 3 so it should
be fine
just I mean they're updating right
they're just not updating right
updating I thought it was like a up AIS
problem like different up AIS but I
don't think
so what if you ALS wait your Z is y is
that what you did on
purpose your Z is well Y is up no but
you made your z y on your
light yeah that's everywhere though it's
because uh we XZ is the plane and Y is
up so the Box no no no that's not what
I'm
saying Z right
I'm okay so it's the Drone XY right the
2D plane 3D is XZ and then Y is the up
AIS okay okay okay okay okay so
everything is like that in this renderer
and this in this okay
okay
I I question If position. X
is Vector 3's internal attributes
XYZ
yeah
[Music]
okay this is so odd
is it XYZ or are they just
values it's XY x.y doz for Vector
3 okay I I use this everywhere as well
see
okay fair enough fair enough
I wonder if this is a limitation of the
r lights file that I
pulled I mean this one does look kind of
shitty
dox I just find it odd that I don't call
update light values anywhere it only
calls it one time and then create light
to move
it so when have to move stuff you can't
just update the value you have to you
have to send it to the Shader so this is
just a wrapper function you see it says
set Shader
value so you can't just modify light
Target even though you've already sent
this to the Shader because it just
copies the data and then if you want to
update it you have to send another
light directional equals zero light
Point does this just start
counting so Rayo has a thing he has an
example of him moving a light and he's
doing pretty much exactly what you're
doing he's doing lights index. position
dox and it's dragging the light all
around I'll link it in uh
chat it seems to be doing what you're
doing so there's something preventing
because if you click the ball and drag
it around it it it'll uh it'll
mask they call so this is in set up
light but then they also update the
light sh do shadow
it's good for shadow can't do this
because it'll
just this won't move it
right what are you referring to this
doesn't move the light doesn't move if
you don't call update light
values it would seem that the position
is
wrong the position is for sure wrong for
whatever reason but it's also like I
don't know how the hell a
point it looks like a
spotlight it definitely doesn't look
like a point light because it should be
hitting a bunch of other things
un pause
X
light you can clearly see that this is
like a spotlight
did you edit create light at
all okay they have a different crate
light for the uh moving ofo
you think it's the do active attribute
that would just toggle it wouldn't
it thing got this has a 10 ation L
position attenuation so when you make
this bloody thing it does enabled type
position Target
color is what it uses position
Target
color typ position Target color right
type position
color so it doesn't deal with any of the
attenuation or anything that's just
there for no
reason also it looks like the max light
is not like a true
max um in the example I shared he goes
up to
16 light point is
one and
this wait wait you said like yeah yeah
know you're right if light Point light
normalize
yeah draw light
M light
position you want to print it you want
to print your light position
I mean I can print the light position
but it is the Drone position right well
maybe we tried to verify that all right
you want me to print
like3 to 30 on these axes and then Y is
five what we're setting it
to oh okay hold I think mine was behind
on the stream okay
so where did you okay you printed that
and then
so this is if you put it
under if you to see uhhuh I don't know
how it's still lighting up
anything it looks like some light leaks
through or
up
Dr does this go inside of a begin
render so begin drawing
mode do they not
begin if lights do
active it looks like it's just in begin
drawing on
this I don't know what dirty lights
are drawing begin mode 3D and then begin
Shader mode
uh I have Shader mode
before mode
3D maybe that screws it
up I I would doubt it but maybe
my God there's so many different render
drone
functions I would have just made one
function
where is this being called is it all
being called at the bottom Rend
end I was just trying to see like where
things are being actually called
now are you not allowed to update the
position in the
Shader in that like FS
file I'm just wondering if you're not
allowed
to no this is the same
thing actually this is yes this the same
same thing
maybe um maybe you're not supposed to do
this at all in the the draw
right I mean that's a weird ass behavior
for to like kind of update it
though
maybe very weird B
Behavior well it's still [ __ ]
screwy and it deleted my UI
but yeah this doesn't do anything
here that's weird
I'm suspicious of update light values
MH well it is updating the life values
just to the wrong
thing well I'm suspicious of calling it
at
all well they call it right here to like
update the toggles to turn lights on and
off
but they don't update it when they move
it they don't move it here yes they do
oh not in this one they don't there's
move
light
this which one you want no yeah that one
no no no different the one the one I
linked in chat yeah that one does that's
a different script right
does this one have move no this one
doesn't the other one is the other one
has
it this is by the way you can do cool
stuff like
this it looks like its light position is
a vector
two in this one maybe because it's top
[Music]
down uh gu
so okay and
then but then they do lights of
slot I mean slot's just an
index Max
lights and then they
set but then did they ever do set Shader
value on
stuff how do they not set the Shader
value oh does this not
have
wait they have blend
modes uh is this not using a
Shader yeah this is not using a Shader
man
right yeah this is them doing it without
a Shader this is no Shader
lighting
right I think this Ray casting or
something yeah yeah this is raycast
lighting how do you know that well first
of all it's an example shapes it's not
an examples um shaders and there's no
Shader being loaded and if you look at
the logic they're just drawing like
they're just drawing triangle fan or
whatever like there's not actually a
Shader being loaded this is just them
drawing like a light sphere and then
black
triangles so this is this is how you
fake lighting
basically oh okay well I guess that's
doesn't actually look like this right
this is like ridiculously
hard
yeah so this one is not the one to look
at all right yeah it's a bad example I
guess then damn
okay humor me what what if you add a
action in your do C file like just put
it on the letter like G or something and
see if that can directly move the light
at
all to your mouse or
something or or whatever you know just
like have like when you press G it like
jumps like 10 spaces to the
right okay
um to see if like it even does anything
and is it moving the position or the
Target and how it's
moving I don't think you'd even have to
like change anything I I think you just
have
to because light's a part of client
right or
say just do like light position. X like
plus 10 or
something yeah and then I would comment
out the light on for the Drone
entirely so is key down this should be
is key down
wait it's still attached to the drones
yeah but watch
this so This one doesn't have a light
now it get slide
back you see the
flicker I'm like catching up on stream
it's as you know like 5 10 seconds
behind or whatever so the red one
doesn't have a light right now now it
does now it doesn't
it does the red
one yeah this red one right
here
there I C look at it light I delete this
light it goes to the center I take it
light
back oh I think I see the flickering now
okay right so here's it light and I put
it in the center I take it
it's very weird because it's like okay
can I just put it at like
so now you just teleported it to 2020
but it's like it's facing this way it's
still a spotlight I'm pretty sure it's a
bad map to see it
but okay here now you can see
it oh wait hang on yeah right here
it thinks this is a light at 25 and
20 so I don't know why just that all the
point
lights is there like some translate or
some
like some transformation there's got to
be another translate going on
maybe but I don't know the point oh I
have an idea
Shader end Shader mode begin Shader mode
end Shader mode begin Shader mode this
how you do
it um I do begin and end when I'm trying
to keep things away
from whatever I uh let me find out where
I did it in Tower clim but I did I did
specifically have to like remove things
out of the Shader realm to do various
things that is for sure a problem that
you
like
um in order
to not have the light on my goal Cube I
end Shader mode I drew the cube and then
I begin Shader mode
afterwards so light does not affect it
at
odd I mean it's on the [ __ ] plane
thing here what if I just do this okay
okay okay what what if you update the
light not in the render
drone that's what I did
oh I thought you were doing it in the
same render drone function
memory Matrix what drae
oh I think I put this from too far down
go
here right no it you go
here I got to get dinner soon like
starving here want this bug to not be
bugged this is crazy even just drawing
this one Matrix it still has a
bug see that we're literally just
drawing
I guess there's
this we'll just double
check
nope okay so we're not even drawing
anything and it's still this bloody
thing is
not wait it's moving without even render
drone being
how is it
what
weird I'm confused how it's doing
anything with all the drawing
off while it's drawing on the it's the
did you already pull out the light
updating away from the render drone
drawing what begin drawing right why is
there no begin
drawing uh
what you
just all right that that may be a
problem how was that the
thing is begin drawing being called
somewhere else I think so begin
drawing in clear background right yeah I
do begin drawing clear background in the
beginning
I do begin drawing clear background and
for some reason I have end Shader
mode why do I have that
[Music]
render so somehow you don't need to call
begin drawing it still runs but this
doesn't fix it
client oh I just have extra and Shader
mode for no
apparently the cone is confusing me so
much yeah I know right like
how like how is this cone even coning
yeah Point LS don't do that like it
would have to hit a material of some
kind it's hitting the
plane but still doesn't do that it
should be no but it would hit the plane
in all in all around it yeah you think
so if I create what if I create the
light here that's what I was saying like
earlier is just draw a
sphere what if I at
20 what if I do
this so you're just moving it to the the
right by
20 yeah it's still like addicted to z0
somehow do you have to recompile or
something in cake with all this
weird
make I mean it's consistent with how it
renders regardless of how you create
it okay
so is it
like do we have it
if you turn off the whole updating with
its whole position and just having the
light it we've confirmed that it just
sit it stays still and is not
directional right it's what if you just
eliminate like you comment out the whole
like just from the original at the
center it looks the lights all look fine
if they're at the center and in fact if
you know a bot moves to the CER C the
light looks reasonable but like it
starts stretching as soon as it moves
from the center
work wait how the hell is this function
even work
work dude this function's undefined
behavior isn't
it oh wait no it's because it's
returning it's returning the struct so
this is actually returning a copy of the
light
okay so you're not adjusting anything so
this is just returning a copy of the
light it's not returning it by reference
at all yeah well you can't because it's
it's not
all right what this is on the stack you
can't return a reference to
this well then how did you do the other
example with oh because that one wasn't
real light that's right it was like so
you're just setting the values for the
Shader is all you're doing here
scpt the script doesn't look wrong
because the demo
is I could it be the camera that this
doesn't work with the
camera I mean I feel like its camera is
running around in the circle right
now in the
example oh you're saying the
orthographic okay
nope perspective Cam's the
same
okay does it mean how about Z up I mean
this will totally break
everything so now that just looks weird
and it doesn't work right yeah so not
that not
Target Target we're setting to zero
right well this camera
Target light Target I
meant we're setting it to a vector zero
it doesn't even use that if it's a point
light
true
it doesn't use any of that
what's this camera
pause set
Shader hang on camera
Shader did they do this
and their small
example think they even have this code
here yes they do update the Shader with
the camera view Vector where it
says in the in the while
loop at the top oh they do have
this this is update camera
update camera must be some function
somewhere because I I've never used
it well this doesn't do anything
also camera
position Shader
value Vector View
but okay I think that's just the orbital
thing is when you do that on the update
camera I don't think this does anything
either yet
okay no it has to be doing it by
reference some way somehow because when
it's in its example when you're using
the keys they're turning it off yeah but
I think that what they do is look if you
where the
keys is key press they're just doing
light zero. enabled is not enabled yeah
but then they then they do right here
update light value Light update light
values at the bottom or where right here
oh okay they loot up they Loop through
and do that okay okay
yeah I mean this is Bizarro
all right I got like 30 minutes same I
think that's about as it until I pass
out so yeah this is a directional light
right
here so this is what directional would
look like okay that actually seems
directional because it's like super
coning so it is a point light but like
why does it splash the way it
does it's almost like it's spawning in
like I don't like it's like only affect
a certain
Dimension yeah why is it only why is it
only affecting you can see as well it
just went over and it's like it's only
worked in this one
axis I
mean it's yeah it's only is on is it on
the wrong
axis I mean what would cause this like I
this is like you can't just put it close
to the plane that will cause a surcle
it has to be it would have to be sloped
is that is it at an angle that would
cause it if it's sloped if it's at an
angle no but it should still create a
circle no it's still a circle it doesn't
matter yeah
there's it it would have to be an object
or not even like how it's [ __ ] weird
it's like it's like black holing into
space I don't know maybe black holes
bending the light do you think it's a
box 2D no there's no way box 2D screws
with I don't think it touches open
GL
doesn't what on Earth is going on with
this stupid
it's like pulling it when it moves and
then it gets really small when
it's I swear it's going to be something
like really simple oh of
course what is going on it doesn't look
like it's like lighting stuff up either
oh no that's lighting this
that's but then like where's this light
coming
from like
this where's the bright white yeah
that's what I'm also I'm in agreement
with that like where's the bright white
coming from cuz right now it should all
be dark right like turned off the lights
it looks like you're shining a spotlight
at
this it's
bit th those feel like Point lights the
ones on the walls
here yeah it's not even lighting up this
side it's like shining through
can we revert back to the concept where
we turn off the light attaching to the
drones and then you rerender it and then
press space and Watch What Happens well
right here this light goes to right here
way but that kind of feels like a point
light
ones why is it like attached it's like
Str this
if I pull this Fork do I have to have
any other things on dependencies on my
machine to
scages for the
compile it'll like tell you okay fair
enough and then do I just do press like
cake and then it
goes uh yeah to
okay so I don't actually see the Spheres
that are supposed to be with these
things all right then position is
position is screwed see so it's light
position
X so I have draw oh but I'm not draw in
a draw
call wrap a draw call right around it I
think you can only do that once per
frame
we see
spheres don't see
spheres uh we're not in mode 3D we're
not in Shader
mode well you're in 3D oh okay you just
needed to add it all right so I mean
this is where it thinks the lights are
now but are those where the players are
no it's in the
wrong it's just moving on one axis did I
get this wrong h
on position x a light position
Z yeah so like look this is right on its
head this is where it thinks the light
[ __ ]
what just to be sure this
now the light isn't
affecting the
Spheres it's like moving around but like
it's it's like facing the [ __ ] Center
for no it's a point like facing the
center that's not how Point light
works is there pointl implementation
wrong I don't think
so I mean it works great on Tower climb
and I've moved the lights around before
but not like as a function
call we tried doing it statically still
didn't
work I can go into Tower climb and see
if and see maybe it's something
within like if I can make it move and
work fine in Tower climb then there's
something funky Happening
Here MH
cuz I have them just in fixed location
so let me see if I can mess with that
real
quick I mean it looks like from what I'm
seeing here it
should
and all right where are my lights at
where are my lights
all right so there's my
light it's right there
all right now something screw on on your
end
yeah because I can move I just tried
moving my light M and it has no problem
running
around but let me see if I change the
light color if if that'll make a
difference
like I'm just like I can't possibly
think what the hell this could be
right all where the [ __ ] is this light
Point okay my lights a Shader but how do
what is the third value of this thing
called
color color okay
see if
it's mode 3D right
begin what if I just do
let's let's give it like the minimal
possible opportunity to screw up
here okay what if I move all the lights
and change all their colors what happens
yeah I mean I'm even able to adjust the
color of my lights as they're
like as things are happening so there's
any like I think there there definitely
some fckery going on it's like the
loop let's see they have this demo
here and the loop is so when I when I
update my light values in terms of like
the other [ __ ] that's going on
I'm I'm not drawing the light anymore
I'm only updating its value in a loop of
Max lights it is outside of blend modeh
mhm it is in between 3D and
drawing uh between so after drawing but
before
3D no that's that's prop way it is also
inside of
3D so it's inside of 3D it's inside of
drawing it is not inside blend mode
mode I think it's inside Shader mode
unless one of the other functions turns
it off at some
point okay so if I put this now
back well we're going to say put this
back
into here cuz do you want to see what it
looks like on my when I move it and and
do things I I know what it's supposed to
look like I just don't know what the why
it's not doing
that all right and it doesn't seem to be
the thing is it doesn't seem to
be I have it in the order that they have
it as far as I can tell unless I've like
really screwed up here
so on mine I was just passing client
lights directly
to um update light values I didn't pass
like the copy I guess what are you doing
you're doing the copy of the ref the
value of the
reference you just pass client lights
client lights is I passed client lights
and then my index like client lights I
you know client lights at index
I that is this which is I guess the
effectively the same thing as that right
well the thing is it is updating it's
not like it's not
updating it's drawing it wrong somehow
it shouldn't screw it up like the
perspective
um camera view
Vector points toward Z
either okay I I got to get food I'm like
starving
here yeah
yeah damn it I like this is going to
drive me nuts
though this
I all right I'm gonna hop off get some
food and relook at it later see if grock
is genius I doubt it
just for fun getting
food are you gonna you like why is my
light psychotically
wrong well it thinks that this is from
Minecraft so it's [ __ ]
stupid rip all right I'll see you later
all right see
you thanks folks I will uh be back
tomorrow
start the repo if you want to support
the project offer. all that good stuff